people of the internet retro Records who
are here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and today I'll
be going through my top 10 beginner tips
for the Legend of Zelda tears the
kingdom and I want to stress here these
are beginner tips this would be really
great for people who maybe never played
breath of the wild or maybe people who
it's been a long time since you played
played breath of the wild and you need a
bit of a refresher on it this video is
for you the first area of the game where
you start your adventure essentially
serves as the game's tutorial and while
I'm sure you'll be ready to get to the
main part of the game you should
definitely take your time here tears of
the Kingdom even though it's a direct
sequel to breath of the wild and
contains some of the same gameplay
elements it also introduces quite a few
new mechanics there are so many menus
and items to understand as well as a
pretty complex control scheme that
fortunately has been improved from the
first game so when you're on this Sky
Island I would really take the time to
familiarize yourself with the controls
to understand the basics while you only
have a few items in your inventory
because trust me it will not take long
before you have a menu that looks like
this there are a few options in the menu
I want to call your attention to as well
the first is the camera Sensitivity I
found the default setting way too low
and even the high setting wasn't Snappy
enough for me so I turned this all the
way up and it feels much better now you
also have the option to completely
disable the HUD if you want that more
immersive feel there's a setting for
gyro aiming it is enabled by default and
I have to say it feels really good this
certainly isn't anything new and games
have been doing this for a while now but
frankly I've never been a huge fan here
though I actually found myself using it
often and if you're not familiar with
this it's just a very subtle tilt of
your controller regardless of which
switch controller you're using when
you're aiming with the bow and it's
actually going to allow you to sort of
pinpoint I still use the right stick to
sort of set the shot up but then I do
use the gyro for that sort of pinpoint
accuracy to be a little bit more precise
and lastly I prefer B to jump an X for
Sprint so I enable this option right
here but this one is purely what you
find the most comfortable you'll also
want to make sure you really read
carefully anytime the game explains a
mechanic to you I know for a lot of
people there can be a tendency to skip
through tutorial menus quickly don't do
that here again because of all the
control trolls all of these abilities
all of these items it's going to be
really important that you understand
sort of the Baseline the foundation and
this beginning area that's really the
sole purpose of it is to teach you all
of those Basics again all right number
two this tutorial area is also going to
be a great place for you to familiarize
yourself with how weapons work in tears
of the kingdom yes they do still break
down like in breath of the wild but
there's a pretty significant change here
this time and it all comes down to the
fuse ability so if you're completely new
with tears of the Kingdom here's
basically how it works you do not get
just the master sword and that's your
only weapon throughout the game in
breath of the wild and now in tears of
the Kingdom you can find weapons all
over the map from all different types of
enemies and then you can use those
weapons in battle and then some would
say unfortunately Nintendo has
implemented a system where these weapons
will break down over time and they can
actually break down even faster if
you're using them in the wrong way so
let's say you're trying to use a weapon
like a spear to do your mining that is
going to make the spear break down much
faster than if you use something like a
blunt weapon that is much better for the
mining now I will say I was not a huge
fan of this breaking down mechanic the
first time in breath of the wild I
eventually got used to it but so far in
tears of the Kingdom I'm okay with it
and it really all comes down to that
fusibility I mean it truly is a game
changer there are so many different
items and tears of the Kingdom that can
be fused to give a weapon more
Properties or make it significantly more
powerful you'll want to really
familiarize yourself with with weapons
in your inventory require two-handed
because while these usually have
stronger attacks you'll lose the ability
to hold up your Shield whenever you're
using them and again because a fuse
Shields offer more utility and even more
attack power than ever before thanks to
some of the items that you confuse to
your Shield don't be afraid to
experiment and get creative here bows
make a return and again thanks to the
fuse mechanic they are more powerful
here you can fuse Keith's eyeballs to
give them the ability to home in on the
nearest Target bomb flowers for a big
explosion and so much more also don't
forget about your abilities in combat
because there are clever ways that you
can use them in battle as well now there
are some pretty tough enemies that
you'll encounter in tears of the Kingdom
you'll be cruising along thinking hey
these mobs aren't too challenging and
then out of nowhere you'll run into an
enemy that far outmatches your current
abilities as a result of this it's going
to be very important that you learn how
to manage your health in battle which
love it or hate it means you'll need to
get used to cooking and making a habit
of doing it regularly one of the big
changes breath of the wild made when
comparing to previous Zelda games is
that you don't find Hearts to refill
your health out in the world the primary
way that you'll hear in tears especially
early game is by cooking dishes and then
eating those dishes when your hearts are
low now yes there are other ways to heal
like fairies and resting at Stables but
eating meals is something you're going
to need to remember throughout the
entirety of the game as it's a great way
to heal in the middle of fights and
here's an area where Zelda is quite a
bit more forgiving than a lot of modern
action RPGs like say Elden ring because
you can actually pause in the middle of
these fights I mean you can be down to
your last heart milliseconds away from
getting hit but if you pause the game
you can eat one of your dishes to
restore your health I mean you could be
falling from the sky you can be climbing
doesn't matter as long as you can pause
the game you can eat your meal Now by
discovering certain recipes you'll even
be able to make meals that give you
higher attack power more stamina Etc I
mean the list goes on and on and on all
right now all of that being said death
is actually not too punishing in tears
the Kingdom at least in most situations
don't get me wrong there's some
situations later in the game where you
definitely don't want to die but like
right here for example especially when
it comes to items so this is early in
the game again but let's just say that I
waste I don't know a couple of these oh
bomb flowers bomb flowers are actually
pretty hard to come by at least early in
the game so let's say I fused one of
these and I shoot it over there so that
takes me down to eight then I have seven
let's go ahead and shoot one over here
and then let's say that I accidentally
say that I because I don't think this
guy will even be able to take us out so
let's say that we accidentally get too
close fire it in and look at that so in
a lot of games we would restart we'd be
pretty far from where we were and we
would lose all of those bomb flowers
that is actually not how it works in
tears of the Kingdom the vast majority
of the time you will start almost right
back exactly where you were and here's
the really good news guys look at our
inventory here let's go back to the
front and there you can see I'm right
back up to eight bomb flowers so don't
be too afraid of death in the game
especially early because far more often
than not you're going to start very
close to where you were and you really
won't have lost anything you'll get all
your items back so that is a really nice
quality of life I guess feature that
makes it a little bit less difficult
than it otherwise would be and that also
leads us right into our next tip here
which is don't be afraid to experiment
and explore if I had to give you a
single piece of advice that one would
probably rank out above all others
because this game more than any game
that I've ever played I mean maybe aside
from some something like Minecraft I
can't think of any other game that
rewards you for experimentation quite
like The Legend of Zelda tears of the
kingdom does let me show you this clip
right here so this is me taking a shield
and fusing it to a mine cart and yes all
the properties that you think would
happen after you fuse it they absolutely
happen here so remember Shield surfing
from the first game if you didn't it was
totally a thing whenever you went
downhill you could jump on your shield
and Surf and it actually worked out
pretty well a lot of times was a fast
way to get around this takes it a step
further I mean you can see how fast I'm
going down this hill right here and then
the other big area where I would say
don't be afraid to experiment in fact it
is strongly strongly encouraged is with
all of your new abilities I mean you
could see this enemy right here moments
ago he actually fused one of these
barrels with his sword over there
so if you look at all these objects here
in the area if I pull out views right
here now it's not gonna let me right now
because this Soldier Reaper has already
been fused with an item oh he fused he
fused a tree branch is that a bow and
arrow no way it is if you
fused the tree branch to the bone arrow
that is great okay the old wooden bow
brought sword that is the one that he
fused together so you can see if I
switch to that right here let me go
ahead and cancel out you can see that
the bow is on the end of this sword
right now which is just hilarious I
don't even think it will increase it
yeah it doesn't look like it increases
the damage of it at all so what I can do
is I can go into the menu here let me go
over to my weapons and find that one
right here and I'm just going to press a
and then we can say destroy fuse
material so it's not gonna oh it
actually did up it by one but not much
but what I don't have is the fuse
material so the bow and arrow that was
fused to this you lose that that goes
away however now I can go over here and
if I wanted to do something crazy like
he just did I confuse it to this
construct bow I could fuse it to where
did that construct horn go I think we
picked it up by accident we could fuse
it to something like this log right here
we could fuse it to these boards over
here to the zonite charge to the Rusty
Shield
the game will let you experiment and it
encourages you to experiment now having
played for a little bit I know that
there's not really any of these items
that I want to fuse it to except for
maybe that Soldier construct horn right
there but if I just press up on the
d-pad here we can cycle through all of
these items here and I'm not going to
show you some of the ones that I've
gotten here more recently because
they're a little bit more powerful than
what you might be getting right now but
especially at the beginning of the game
you're going to come across things like
this the goblin horn right here so if I
drop that
and then you can see my sword right now
is at level five so if I go into the
fuse menu right here to use it to my
sword look at that it increased it by
four and it even has a visual change as
well you'll actually see it on your
sword there so now we're already at a
nine attack power on this weapon now
when it comes to experimenting and
exploring I encourage this right from
the beginning of the game with one
exception I think you should progress
the game at least until the point where
you get this item right here the one
that you see me using now the paraglider
it doesn't take long stick to the story
missions the main quest and very quickly
within a few hours you're gonna have
this paraglider which just makes such a
huge difference for traversing the world
so that is my next tip is progress the
story until you get the paraglider get
it early and I'm going to show you a
little extra special tip here with the
glider so your stamina bar we're going
to talk more about stamina here in a
second but stamina plays a big role when
you're gliding here so you can see that
green meter depleting and I'm just gonna
let it run out here so we're just gonna
fly and you may find yourself in this
situation a lot because there is so much
to see and do in this game like look at
all those sky islands up there you may
find yourself jumping from one sky
island trying to Glide over to another
and realizing oh it was actually much
farther than I realized and then you're
not able to make it so right here look
at that my stamina ran out now I'm gonna
pause the game just for a second here
you can see Link's exhausted because
he's out of stamina but what's important
to know here is you still have one more
very brief Glide it's very quick but as
long as you activate it right before you
hit the ground then you're gonna be fine
the only other way I could survive is if
we fell into water which looks like
there is a little bit of water nearby
but it's just just too far away We're
not gonna make it so I'm gonna wait till
right about there pull the glider and
then link Falls no harm done and then a
stamina refills and we're ready to go
again and that actually leads us
perfectly into our seventh tip here
which is managing your stamina we talked
a little bit earlier about health
stamina is a little bit different so
it's not like some other games like
Elden ring you know where if you spam
attack in Eldon ring you're eventually
gonna run out and you have to wait
otherwise you can't attack it refills
pretty quickly there but here it only
applies to three things it applies when
I'm running so right here you see me
take off into a Sprint there goes my
green meter slowly depleting now as long
as I stop before it fully depletes link
doesn't really have any sort of side
effects other than you know I have to
stop running for a moment here also as
you guys just saw earlier it affects
when he's gliding as well so you can see
I'm gliding right there whenever you're
hopping off these little small hills and
mountains you're not going to really run
into much trouble with that however if
you're jumping off a sky island like you
just saw me do or a really tall mountain
like the one over there then you
absolutely will run into that being an
issue the other spot where it comes into
play is swimming so where the water is
really an issue with stamina is if
you're trying to cross a large body of
water now I will say this game you don't
always have to resort to swimming where
you could run into some trouble though
is if you jump so let's say I'm not
going to be able to really demonstrate
it from right here but if I kind of
Glide in and then I land in the water
you see my stamina doesn't refill right
there so if you're hitting the water and
you're thinking I can just Glide down
into this large body of water and have
very little stamina left you're going to
be in trouble when you do that because
you're going to hit the water have very
little stamina left and then you're just
going to drown and you're gonna die
right there now the other thing about
stamina that is very forgiving and I've
stopped it right here on purpose if you
just stop your stamina will not go
anywhere so I have to make a decision
right now what do I want to do here do I
want to drop down because I could go
ahead and go down a little bit and
that's going to help me not take as much
fall damage I don't think I would take
any from here but it's kind of it'd be
pretty close right we're sort of on the
verge of where we would take fall damage
I definitely can't make it to the top so
that's out of the question however very
much like health I can pause right in
the middle of this you can do this when
gliding you can do this when swimming
you can do this when climbing and if you
go over to your cooking and the dishes
that you've made you'll want to look for
these that have a little green ring so
anything that will increase your stamina
so it just so happens I need to heal a
few Hearts right now too so this is
actually perfect energizing mushroom
skewer right here instantly refills some
of your stamina wheel so it will go
right away you know not very realistic
but it's very nice as a gameplay feature
so if I eat this right now
even though I am currently hanging on
the side of this Cliff here and then we
go back in look at that my stamina just
refilled by a little bit now I
definitely don't want to dash because if
I Dash and do that little extra jump I'm
not going to have enough but there you
can see by eating that not only did I
refill my hearts I refilled my stamina
just enough for me to make it to the top
of the cliff now and I didn't mention
this when we were talking about health
so I'll mention it here you can increase
your stamina and your hearts the way
that you'll increase these is by
completing the shrines in the game you
complete these shrines you get a spirit
orb once you have four you go to one of
these little prayer Alters there's one
that you'll find very early in the game
just by progressing the story you pray
in front of these little statues and
then you get a choice of whether you
want to add a heart or add a little bit
of stamina and that is totally up to you
you can go back and forth you can go all
stamina for a while and then go to
Hearts vice versa I usually find I'm
more of a heart guy I like to really
build up my health first but for
whatever reason in tears of the Kingdom
I found myself exploring so much that I
really want more stamina so I've
actually been prioritizing that a bit
more here here in the early going all
right for our next tip let's talk about
the map because tears of the kingdom is
such a massive game I mean I'm only
scratching the surface of all this game
has to offer at this point now right now
I'm still showing you guys the starting
area I don't want to give away too much
we're not going to spoil major parts of
the game for you here however it is
going to be very important that you get
used to how to use the map as well as
placing markers throughout the world so
if I click in my right analog stick
right now it's going to pull out the
scope here and you can see at the very
bottom we have what is that six little
indicators for where we can place what I
call a light Beacon so if I point this
right over here that is a shrine that
Shrine is one that I've already
completed so that's why it doesn't have
the little swirly stuff on it but let's
just say it did have the swirly stuff
and you're all the way over here and you
think okay I see the shrine there but
there's no way I can do anything with it
right now you can pull out your scope
right here you can push a to place that
marker down now if I go into my map look
at that it actually shows up as the
little red light Beacon right there now
just remember if you had not yet
discovered this shrine then it's not
going to even show up here like it is
for me the red Beacon though would show
up regardless and so what you could do
here is you could go in select that pin
and you can edit it and you're going to
need to come up with some sort of system
whatever works best for you because you
only have six of these these however you
get 300 so you can place a lot of these
out in the world now there are some
advantages to having the light beacons
though they will actually show up on
your minimap so you see down there in
the bottom right my mini map I have the
yellow one it's kind of facing me
directly right there we've got a purple
one there and then we've got the red one
there the yellow circle that is our next
main mission that we have marked right
now are active Quest so if I zoom in
right there again I also can see the
light Beacon right there however let's
say I go in and I'm going to zoom out
here a little bit and we're going to
change this we're going to change this
from the light Beacon we're going to
edit pin and this is what I've been
using for shrines right here this little
Diamond so when I place the diamond that
does not show up on my mini map and I
also do not get a light Beacon for it so
the light be weekends are really best
for something that you want to find kind
of right then it's not something that
you want to put off and you can do up to
six of them so I mean you don't have to
do them all right then but the great
benefit there is that you can play
something anywhere in the world and then
you're gonna see it whenever you zoom in
with the scope but also in the minimap
on the right hand side moving on to tip
number nine here fast travel tears of
the Kingdom very much like breath of the
wild has an incredibly generous fast
travel system anything that you see
right now that's blue on my map you can
fast travel too now what are all these
blue indicators the majority of them are
shrines so this one right here you can
see is a shrine this one here is a
shrine which it's also reminding me I
need to go in and delete these stamps
now that I've already discovered the
shrine also you will find these Skyview
Towers throughout the world as well
these are really handy I'm actually at
one of these right now so I'm going to
go ahead and hit examine here it's going
to take me to the top when you fly up in
the air like this this gives you your
best vantage point that you will have in
the game I mean it just takes you
incredibly high up and here's the crazy
thing so when I ever you're flying like
this you can also press R3 to pull out
that scope again and it puts you into a
very very slow mode it doesn't
completely stop things you can see those
creatures are still flying there but it
is very slow and there's no time limit
on this I mean I'm sure you would
eventually hit the ground at some point
but like there's a shrine over there
that one's got the little swirly so that
means I have not discovered it yet let's
go ahead and Mark it with a beacon I can
pull out my map right now see oh it's
actually quite a bit further than I
realized let's go ahead and edit the pin
give it a little diamond and we're good
to go now in terms of all of these
things you can fast travel to these
Skyview Towers they're great because you
can have that high vantage point but
anytime you see a shrine that you happen
to be close to I actually haven't
explored this area much yet so let me
see if I can find one that's close by
even if you don't plan on doing the
shrine actually that's perfect right
there there's one right there you can
see the little swirl now for this one
I'm actually going to put the light
Beacon so let's put that down so we can
see that
and then I'm just going to try and fly
straight to it because right now I don't
really have anywhere basically anything
east of this Skyview Tower right here I
have no fast travel point right now but
if I go and fly here I don't even have
to do this Shrine right now if I just
fly here discover the shrine then it
instantly opens that up as a fast travel
point for us but let's see if I can
glide I think I should have just enough
here to make it okay so here we are so
see we discovered the shrine right there
all right now I'm going to show you what
happens we haven't went up and activated
it yet so see how it has this gold color
to it so I could not fast travel to it
just by getting close right there
however all you have to do is walk up
hit examine link will put out his hand
as you're probably familiar with by this
point he'll open up the shrine but then
notice the game does not immediately
Force you in just because you open it
however I have now unlocked this Shrine
so I haven't completed it but now it is
unlocked as a fast travel point so I
could go all the way back let's say we
want to go all the way to
right where we started all right so now
we're all the way back over here in the
Hyrule Field but if I pull out the map
again now this point is open as a fast
travel point for our next and final tip
here oh wait what is this right here let
me examine this this is actually perfect
this is exactly what I wanted to show
you guys because in this game one of the
things that Zelda games have just always
been so good at is making the worlds
feel alive I mean every character feels
like they have their own story their own
little path that they follow right so in
tears of the kingdom it is very
important that you talk to people you
interact with them and you always always
always look for the red text I mean they
make it pretty obvious right but anytime
you see the red text that is just
something you need to pay attention to
far more often than not it's going to
lead to some type of quest or it's
something that you really need to make
sure that you know so right here link
makes ready use of the jump slash
leaping into the air and Swinging his
weapon down with a practiced ease All
crew members should be diligent in their
daily training and Aspire toward that
level of Mastery Captain Haws and then
right there you get the little prompt
press y in midair and you will do the
jump slash so now let's go ahead and let
me switch to something where it will be
really obvious this weapon right here
should be good the soldier Reaper so we
jump
slash there you go that's the jump slash
it isn't safe here all right and then we
have red text Captain haws's Squad of
the monster control crew is going to
engage the monsters around here soon I
bet you by now they're already locked in
combat with the monsters at the lair to
the South the game is Just littered with
things like this also anytime you see an
exclamation point above someone's head
definitely make the time to talk to that
person but honestly even more than the
quest this is what makes this game feel
so alive this is something that Zelda
games have always been so so good at is
just making this world really come to
life now I would love to hear from new
Zelda players to see what other
questions you guys still have about
tears of the Kingdom so comment below
ask away if we get enough questions I'll
go back and try to answer them in a
future video and if you'd like to see me
play through tears of the Kingdom I've
been uploading my playthroughs over on
our let's play channel so you can check
that video out on the right side of your
screen now that's episode one as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon